ιάσεις ένα παιδί μέσα κ από τα σοσάλμήνια υπάρχουν διοπτιες του παιδικής προνοες υμφωνό μαζί
σας είναι πολύς κληρών αυτό τω φαινούμενων καταβάλλορω είναι διέχερες προσπαθίες για αντιμετόπισητοφανωμένωυν έχουμε συνερκασία
με τη γρό πο ποχιιδικώ λομέα για την παιδική ποογραφία και συνεργαζόμαστε αντελούμε αρκετές πληροφορίες
αλλά έχουμε και δικέθμασε δι υποθέσις υπάρχουν δύ όμως όψεις τις παιδικής προνοραφίασε υπάρχουν ν
αυτοί οι οποίο προσπαθούν να αντιλήσουν οι λικών από παιδιά εδώ στην κύπρο και αυτοί
που εμπορεύονται οι κατεβάζουν τετοιονιλικών για αδικοίι τους ικανοποίη ο πρώτος τομέας είναι συνίδος τα
θύματα είναι παιδιά από κατριών νέχρειδεκαέξε των είναι αυτοή κρισιμί λεκία λικία είναι και αυτοί
που είναι εβάλοτα τα παιδιά δεν ξέρουνται τους γίνεται οι κοπέλλες αυτές συνείωτοτι είναι κοπέλες
αλλά και αγώνι κι λλά συνήδω είαι κοπέλλα στα θήματα αρχίζουν να ανακαλύπτουν των σεεξοαλιγώ
του σαθέλεται αυτόν και αρχίζουν να ασχολούνται λίγο περισότερμα αυτά τα θέματα και είναι εκεί
που είναι και βάλοντες και τέλουν ιλικώμε ευκολία αλλά υπάρχουν και αυτοί οι επιτήδη οι
οποίοι πλησιάζουνται παιδιά το λογόμενων κρούμιμε ψεύτικο προφί απλησιάσωμε μιαν αντίλικοι και να προσπαθίσωυ να
αντλήσω οιλικοθείται εδίτιο είται φωτογραφίες οι ότι δήποτε από την έλικαι αυτή τή ιαφορές που
διαευνώσε ασυπόθεση να ανοίξει σκινητώ και αυτά που έβλεπες να μην αντέξιστέση με την εμπηρία
που έχεις εφισήσα φυσικά εγώ σκεφτμε